en el último vídeo definimos una
transformación que de hecho era una
rotación en un ángulo theta que tomaba
valores vectoriales en r2 y nos arrojaba
una versión rota de ese mismo vector en
r2 verdad y lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es esencialmente extender este
concepto de las rotaciones pero ahora lo
vamos a hacer en r3 así que voy a
definir una transformación de rotación
en un ángulo theta y de hecho le voy a
poner aquí un 3 no significa que estoy
multiplicando por 3 sólo nos va a
indicar que ahora estamos trabajando en
tres dimensiones entonces vamos a tomar
vectores en r3 y nos va a escupir una
versión rota de ese vector pero en r3
ahora tú pensarás que en r3 pues es
difícil de entender lo que es una
rotación verdad en el plano digamos solo
tenemos una dirección angular verdad
pero en r3 pues tenemos que decir si
vamos a rotar alrededor de que de un eje
de rotación verdad en este caso vamos a
pensar que sea alrededor
del eje x es decir uno de los ejes va a
ser nuestro eje de rotación en general
es muy difícil pensar en una rotación
con ejes en general pero cuando tomamos
rotaciones alrededor del eje x o del eje
o del eje z es muy sencillo de
interpretar entonces vamos a rotar
alrededor alrededor del eje x que el eje
x y esto simplemente va se puede
generalizar para también los otros ejes
de hacer el eje llegó el eje z verdad
pero todo esto va así va a seguir siendo
la misma idea del vídeo anterior es
decir de las rotaciones en el plano y
para para ir aclarando todas estas ideas
vamos a hacer vamos a pintar nuestros
ejes
hacerlo derechito
y ahí tenemos nuestro eje z nuestro eje
y
este es el eje z este es el eje y y por
supuesto aquí anda el eje x muy bien
entonces si vamos a rotar alrededor del
eje x quiere decir que todo este eje no
se mueve simplemente vamos a girar todo
el espacio en esta dirección muy bien
entonces solo lo único que se queda fijo
es este eje x y todo lo demás rota
alrededor de él por ejemplo si nosotros
tuviéramos algo algo más o menos
sencillo de visualizar es qué pasaría si
yo tengo aquí un vector en el plano
detalle que esté este vector se
encuentra en el plano detalle que lo
vamos a pensar solo en este plano y si
aplicamos la transformación de rotación
pues nos va a escupir otro vector otro
vector de la misma magnitud que haya
rotado sobre ese mismo plano verdad pero
bueno a lo mejor si pensamos en un
vector que no esté exactamente en el
plano detalle digamos que a lo mejor
una coordenada aquí este en x distinta
pues a la hora de rotar esa coordenada x
no se mueve verdad entonces más o menos
esta misma distancia se conserva y
deberemos tener este vector de aquí
este vector de aquí porque entonces para
ir corrigiendo un poco el dibujo lo
dejamos de esta forma y este vector pues
se ve que ya no está en el plano x de
verdad y sin embargo si roto un ángulo
también de teta teta grados ok
espero que sea un poquito claro el el
dibujo al menos yo creo que ya tienes la
idea bien de qué es lo que estamos
haciendo a la hora de rotar alrededor
del eje x y cómo se como pensamos que
estas rotaciones como en el vídeo
anterior son transformaciones lineales
entonces podemos decir que esta función
la rotación en tres dimensiones
de un vector x en un ángulo theta quizás
aquí debería además ponerle alrededor de
kg pero bueno queda claro de qué estamos
hablando
debe ser la multiplicación de una matriz
por un vector donde esta matriz es de 3
x 3 muy bien ya eso lo hemos visto
anteriormente y como es que lo hacíamos
pues primero nos tomábamos la matriz
identidad que en este caso la matriz de
3 por 3 que tiene unos en la diagonal y
0 en todos lados verdad esta es nuestra
matriz identidad donde éste me da en los
vectores de la base de una base de r3
verdad los vectores canónicos la base
canónica entonces va hasta ver hacia
dónde van a dar estos vectores para que
podamos construir esta matriz y está
dado de la siguiente forma la matriz a
la matriz
simplemente tiene como vectores columnas
a la rotación aplicado a cada uno de
estos vectores verdad este sería nuestro
primer vector columna el siguiente
vector columna sería a la hora de
aplicarlo al segundo al segundo vector
que en este caso 0 10 verdad y la
tercera columna la tercera columna es
aplicar esta rotación a nuestro vector
ok y esta es la matriz
estos son vectores columna ok entonces
vas a ver a dónde van a dar estos estos
tres estos tres vectores después de
rotar para determinar exactamente quién
es la matriz que define esta
transformación línea muy bien entonces
basta ver el primero de los ejemplos es
qué pasa cuando nos tomamos el vector a
uno es decir el 100
si nos fijamos aquí en este dibujito del
vector 100 se encuentra exactamente
sobre el eje x verdad sólo tiene
coordenada en x0 tanto en ye como en
zeta entonces este vector se encuentra
más o menos aquí es este blanco que
estoy pintando pero si es este vector
blanco y estamos rotando alrededor del
eje x dijimos que todo el eje x se queda
fijo es decir es como se agarrarán una
varilla y le estuvieran rotando
alrededor de sus dedos verdad lo
estuvieran girando en realidad la
varilla si lo hacemos muy de forma
perfecta no se debería mover sólo se
está moviendo sobre sí misma verdad
entonces esta varilla que representa el
eje x no se mueve todo lo demás si está
girando pero el eje no entonces este
vector es 1 sigue siendo el mismo vector
después de aplicarle la transformación
este es el 1
pero muy bien ahora vamos a ver qué pasa
con la rotación del vector 0 10 entonces
para eso vamos a dibujar nuestros ejes
vamos a dibujar nuestros ejes aquí
estamos pensando que está el eje iv y el
eje z si nosotros tomamos el vector 1010
estamos pensando estamos pensando en
este vector de aquí
este es el vector 2 y al ahora
derrotarlo en un ángulo theta tenemos
este otro vector muy bien entonces basta
determinar sus coordenadas de este
vector ahora recordemos que estamos
rotando alrededor del eje x que
esencialmente es digamos el eje que que
está saliéndose de la pantalla directo
hacia tus ojos entonces estamos rotando
en esta dirección verdad así que este
ángulo de aquí es un ángulo teta y lo
que hay que hacer es determinar
simplemente las coordenadas sobre el
plano receta verdad justo como dijimos
aquí si tengo un vector en el plano ya z
a la hora de rotarlo se queda ahí mismo
entonces construimos nuestro nuestro
triángulo vamos a construir este
triángulo y simplemente se vuelve un
problema de funciones trigonométricas
porque sabemos que esta distancia es uno
simplemente rotamos el vector canónico
que ya tenía norma 1 y nos falta
determinar la base que nos determina la
coordenada ye y la altura que nos
determina la coordenada z verdad
si tenemos este triángulo podemos
utilizar el coseno del ángulo del coseno
del ángulo simplemente es el cateto
opuesto que es este de aquí perdón es un
cateto adyacente es el cateto adyacente
sobre la hipotenusa pero la hipotenusa
mide 1 así que esto simplemente es
esta esta esta coordenada es coseno de
teta verdad entonces vamos a ir
redondeando estas ideas
aquí tenemos 0 verdad no estamos
moviéndonos en la dirección x y aquí la
base la base de este vector es coseno
del ángulo ahora bien qué pasa con el
cateto opuesto si tomamos la función
seno de teta vamos a tener cateto
opuesto sobre hipotenusa que es el
cateto opuesto entonces esta altura que
es la coordenada zeta es el seno del
ángulo el seno del ángulo esté muy bien
vámonos con el último vámonos con el
último de nuestros vectores y déjenme
hacer otro dibujito para que quede muy
claro qué es lo que estamos haciendo
otros ejes
de hecho aquí vamos a necesitar
extenderlo y ahora vamos a tener aquí
nuestro vamos a tener nuestro vector
canónico de 3
digamos que este es 3 y a la hora de
rotar en un ángulo teta
aquí tendremos este ángulo theta y
tendremos que construir nuevamente un
triángulo vamos a construir este
triángulo muy bien otra vez podemos
utilizar las funciones trigonométricas
para determinar qué es lo que va a
ocurrir con esta altura que es nuestra
coordenada zeta que ésta es nuestra
coordenada z y la coordenada y la altura
otra vez ez y la distancia es ok
entonces si nos consideramos el seno del
ángulo si consideramos el seno de
nuestro ángulo es el cateto puesto que
es este de aquí sobre la hipotenusa que
otra vez es 1 entonces el seno del
ángulo va a ser el cateto opuesto que es
la coordenada y pero si nos fijamos aquí
estamos en la dirección negativa
entonces este es menos seno de teta así
que nuevamente como no nos estamos
moviendo en la dirección x esto va a ser
cero y aquí va a ser menos seno detecta
qué pasa con el coseno del ángulo con el
coseno del ángulo pues simplemente es el
cate
adyacente de aquí sobre la hipotenusa
verdad pero el cateto adyacente es la
altura entonces la altura resultó ser el
coseno del ángulo y ya con esto que
tenemos poder hemos construido la matriz
que define esta transformación verdad
tenemos esta matriz esta matriz de aquí
es la matriz de rotación la matriz de
rotación en tres dimensiones alrededor
del eje x en un ángulo theta es esta
matriz al multiplicarlo por x lo que me
define la transformación lineal verdad y
esto estamos pensando que es una
rotación alrededor del eje x muy bien
entonces este vídeo en realidad
consistió en ver una general
generalización de las rotaciones en r3
tu puedes intentar la misma idea
alrededor del eje o del eje z pero bueno
este es un caso especial donde
trabajamos con el eje x pero puedes usar
el mismo procedimiento como ya lo he
dicho para definir alrededor de los ejes
jay-z y después ir aplicando
una tras otra ir componiendo las
rotaciones para ir generando rotaciones
más complicadas pero bueno espero hayas
encontrado esto un poco útil es una
pequeña extensión de lo que hicimos en
r2